every step of john mccain's passing was
choreographed a scripted departure a
clarion call for America Washington
National Cathedral the setting for a
deliberate display of political unity I
am
resurrection and I am life says the Lord
three former presidents and the current
one noticeably absent bidding farewell
to a war veteran a political maverick
and a doting father I am here before you
today saying the words I have never
wanted to say giving this speech I have
never wanted to give we gather here to
mourn the passing of American greatness
the real thing not cheap rhetoric from
men who will never come near the
sacrifice he gave so willingly he was a
great fire who burned bright from
poignant memories to a pointed message
the America of John McCain has no need
to be made great again because America
was always great it was a steely rebuke
of Donald Trump in all but name and just
as she tried to contrast their conduct
the president was firing off tweets
airing his grievances but Barack Obama
who beat McCain to the White House
showed in death as in life the senator
was always willing to cross the
political aisle for all of our
differences we shared a fidelity to the
ideals for which generations of
Americans have marched and fought and
sacrificed and given their lives we
considered our political battles a
privilege an opportunity to serve as
stewards of those ideals here at home
and to do our best to advance them
around the world george w bush
remembered a man unafraid to antagonize
even when a prisoner of war he was
courageous with a courage that
frightened his captors and inspired his
countrymen he was honest no matter whom
it offended presidents were not spared
among the pool bearers was a russian
dissident poisoned twice vladimir
CaroMont says brushes with death brought
him closer to mccain by inviting him to
take part in his funeral he took a swipe
at Vladimir Putin was an immensely and
deeply personal honor it's also the most
heartbreaking honor he can think of and
I think it's actually symbolic for all
the propaganda talk of john mccain being
an old enemy of Russia you know that
among the select group of people that he
chose to be his pallbearers there'll be
a Russian citizen he was a contrarian
stubborn and deeply conservative on some
issues and he intervened with urgency
till the very end he didn't always get
it right controversially he was a
cheerleader for the Iraq war and in his
recent memoir said I have to accept my
share of the blame he believed though in
the power of American exceptionalism and
he was single-minded about it he prided
himself on taking a stand however
unpopular and in his final good-bye he
was determined to get his voice heard
once again good Adele and Sky News
Washington